new details from metro on tuesday's
shooting involving officers let's get
right out to orko manna who was at that
news conference orco
denise and christian this was a very
dynamic situation for police it started
with a man kidnapping his ex-girlfriend
from her apartment and then dragging her
at gunpoint outside into a local
shopping center take a look at this this
is video just released by metro police
you can see the man identified as mario
martinez holding the woman and pointing
his gun at responding officers he tries
to steal multiple cars to drive away
with her but is not able to he then
drags her through a grocery store and is
seen waving the gun around once outside
police say martinez pointed his gun at
officers his ex-girlfriend was able to
get away and that's when martinez and
police both exchanged gunfire martinez
died at the scene
it's really a nightmare scenario of a
mobile hostage situation
but thankfully
the citizen
that was kidnapped was not hurt the loss
of life obviously in any situation is
sad and tragic for the family members of
that person involved but in this
situation the suspect dictated the
actions of the officers and there was
little left for us to do
after police say the woman was
a little bit injured because martinez
did grab her and if martinez survived he
would have faced several charges we're
live at metro headquarters orco mana
live local now